welcome to a very special edition of a
beginner breakdown I am your host Mike
comer and we just had a big scholastic
chess tournament the Summer Slam bash in
it it was a lot of fun I had a three of
my students in there a Jaden Meyer
strobe a gas shooter one Kevin Zhuang or
the race no one is Kevin goooo or goooo
number two whatever you want to call
them and of course adjourn my my star
pupil that has since got a national
master Lowell Davis to teach them so it
was a lot of fun and I will be off next
week as I will be in Las Vegas so be
sure to follow my tweets and everything
at big comm STL and and see how much
money I end up betting on a cam camera
to take down a Kimbo Slice alright so
that's a bad bet all right all right
well well you can now we will see we'll
see cuz I'm gonna have five large on the
wager
alright but tonight we got so first off
we have Jenna song kids beginners
superstore against Charlie Pitt now I
try to teach Charlie pit a couple times
but you know I
he thought he thinks he knows it all and
you know I told they don't play this
don't play that he's like do it I got
this I know better okay so I said I got
a perfect teacher for you buddy none
other than Harper Evan Smith okay so
Harper I'm Smith's petition for a while
so so let's see if he's progressed at
all all right so Charlie Pitts has the
black pieces so II for a five-night up
396 Bishop c4
we all saw this from last week right so
we know now what to play now so what's
the worst move for black in this
position Knight f6 and Charlie's like
you don't understand Kevin you don't
understand I'm good I one of the play 95
and he gets a big smile
the devilish smile on his face because
that's what we got the Traxler counter
gambit like one of the most unplayable
openings who can ever play in your life
and he's been playing for two three
years but he's still late so excited now
if you're playing a kid that's you know
100 it might work but you're playing
Jenna song 555 over here so she can't
wait she smashes the the pawns and so so
now the whole point of the Traxler
counter gambit is I'm going to take you
took my upon I'm going to take your F
pawn with chat so whenever you're
playing I guess the strikes with
Kerrigan but it's real easy just don't
take the bishop as long as you don't
take the bishop your aces and even Jenna
knows that and now it's like darn you
didn't take my bishop I'm out of luck
here so a Queen's attack so she's got to
move the Queen and so Chomp free rook
now you're down a rook and you got
nothing going for you all right but
chars going to try to mix it up some
more he takes the pawn just fine
if-if-if Jenna really knew what she was
doing she was just take with check right
and then if you black with check the
knight would come down take Queen takes
and then the fork the knight and the
King and white would just be just
crushing even more but but she's like I
don't even care I just saved my night
whatever all right so the knight is
protected by the bishop and so now Queen
then Bishop on the same Lane as the King
so she's like no worries
so Knight to c3 allowing the discovery
and so Charlie makes a pretty
interesting move so he plays check
hoping hoping it
hope chess that it she goes there and
checkmate
but guess what she doesn't she blacks
with the Queen here and it's not looking
too good for Charlie
so Queen takes pawn takes the Knights
under attack the bishop is under attack
okay so two pieces of ours are under
attack you're right so a good way to get
out of this conundrum or whatever it's
just if you can take something with one
of those two pieces like the knight for
instance and then take and now I can
retreat my Bishop to safety instead he's
like yeah let's see let's see what he
decides I'll take the rook all right so
so rook the G one attacks the bishop so
so what move is the most logical move
for black in this position just shout it
out
Bishop h4 excellent just Bishop h4 and
then I'm still protecting the night
instead after Rick g1 he decides to
attack the rook again all right so what
does white do here it's like I could I
could just take the bishop and then the
knight to take the work and you know or
we could really put the hurt on them
here anybody got any ideas what wait
should play here rook takes the bishop
right if we can figure out how to take
it
rook takes Bishop you want to replay
that all right so so robotics the bishop
and now the Knights under attack so
Charlie should you know deviously play
d6 and then the you know the knight
would be protected by the bishop but
instead you Richard she plays Knight up
four so Jenna plays d3 discovered attack
on the night
now d6
and so now yeah Jenna gets gets the
point let's just start taking all your
stuff you know let's go
so king attacks the wreck rook takes the
pawn just take the stuff check Ori got
checking it's like who cares okay now I
want everybody to really look at this
position and for about 30 seconds all
right Dylan sees it right away so let's
just just shout it out
rook AJ excellent okay we don't need to
be looking at all these discoveries or
anything it's like we got a free rook
there's nothing like a free rook right
or you've lost both of his rooks now all
right so much for that Traxler counter
gambit huh you lose the first one I move
five and think you're doing something
special it's like yeah all right
so unfortunately Jenna doesn't see it
she plays it there okay so King up the
g7 so this is easy just remove the
defender right simple so knight retreats
rook attacks the knight rook protects
the night tap the pin piece excellent
general except oh oh if they take here
you have you can you can take with Czech
and the rook takes and then you got the
skewer so if she saw it the whole whole
thing she was like yeah yes he saw yeah
so so he didn't want to take the knight
because because he saw it too so Knight
takes c7 rook up Knight checks now he's
like I gotta take this thing already so
now it takes the pawn King up and then
check and then the when the knight
blocks here it does no good right
because rook takes Knight even though he
tries to go to e7 to no avail it's
checkmate
so now we'll see how my students play
against each other you'll see a very
superb very boring opening but look how
good they do so this is Jaden against a
gas Yoda line here okay
so Jane plays the movie for Agosta e5
Knight f3 knight c6 Bishop c4 there's no
way they're gonna allow the fried liver
attack Bishop c5 castles by move for now
Knight f6 h3 just play a little prevent
offense d6 d3 h6 they're not gonna let
anybody go pin them no way so Knight c3
Castle so everybody is playing solid a
totally equal position it kind of looks
symmetrical huh so they're both playing
great rook e1 can't resist copying them
and so now Bishop e3 attacks the bishop
and yeah and unfortunately at this point
Agosto I mean just take them but in
state plays Bishop D for allowing double
pawns and now he's got no good way to
save this D pawn so one slight little
inaccuracy and things start falling
apart for them so Bishop attacks the
bishops will take it take it
Queen up three you tax the night but he
allows the knight to happen to a 5 here
so d5 and so now I can threaten
something huge here what move can white
make in this position disarrange
the biggest thing in chess which is
obviously checkmate how can white
threatened checkmate in this position
anybody I know two people no all right
go ahead
green g3 excellent I always yeah if you
can threaten checkmate that's not really
hope chest it's just I'm trying to
checkmate you I mean that's the whole
point
all right so he defends it and now we
have tactics here and I can't believe
Jane doesn't see this tactic he does
them the next move does anybody see a
cool check we can play for white yeah
Knight takes a six check okay you can't
take back because of G pawns in a pin
okay but instead plays the move c4
attacks the pawn and so now when it
plays d4 now say oh yeah I can just
check you yes oh alright well better
late than never huh
so Knight g4 Knight takes Queen takes
and so I guys just like I'm gonna take
your take a queen give you double pawns
and I'll see if I can win in the same
game but look he's down Jay has all
eight pawns
and he's only got six so it's gonna be a
really tough endgame for him to do so if
you were aghast you in this position
it's black to move what what's an idea
to try to a threaten a checkmate and
let's say three moves and you're like
what how can he threaten checkmate in
three moves so his first move kind of
works for it but after he kind of stops
the checkmate but the idea is to get
this rook this rook to h6 followed by
King up and then the other rook to h8
okay that should be his idea here and
then just just rule that h-file
cuz rooks love open files you know but
he never really gets the idea going and
and now a white can challenge that
h-file
and yeah you'd much rather have your
rook here than here and so now he's got
the H file and it should be pretty easy
for him to win here check you don't want
your rook here right very passive Oracle
right so so he's going to get counter
play on the Queen side while while black
and have that pawn so blacks well maybe
I don't know
so here a5 hey I think we're getting is
the best move here
alright so takes takes rook takes rook
up so he just gave him a pawn for free
check that good another pawn for free
not good and his I gotcha endgame
technique isn't isn't as good as it
should be but you know he's working on
it and yeah just if you can just trade
rooks consolidate to winning endgame
it's gonna be over pretty quick and you
can't stop both and up let's see his big
technique at the end that's checkmate
alright so so here it is all right Jaden
got them all right
so so so Jane Jane got it but but
unfortunately I gosh you just just
failed to lose a couple pawns in the in
the end game and couldn't couldn't hold
on so we're going to show two games
coming up of a Dillon a visitor from an
April Florida I'll be visiting a Lord
Lord or Dale in November I can't wait
and but they're from the other side of
Florida right Naples
the other side not the Atlantic Ocean
side so so his first game he plays
against Jane well his uh I guess
your second round game against Jane and
it doesn't go so well
but then we'll see them get a big
recovery in the third round and so here
we go uh Dylan has the white pieces so
e4 c5 okay
so gets us Night Out fish up there he
gets castles so Qasim I move for
excellent g6
Knight up Bishop g7 attacks the the
knight but obviously doesn't want to
trade this bishop this pn shadow bishop
because it's gonna hold this whole
castle position together knight f6 fish
up up he gets castled
so so look i mean this doesn't even look
like a beginner game really right I mean
they got their knights out there bishops
out there playing good and this instance
I would've probably played Bishop up
before castle but either's fine and uh
and yeah he really needs to get his
bishop going and it looks like he hasn't
yet rook e8 but uh but they're both
playing very well so you were hitting f7
pretty hard here pinning this pawn but
you know if you want to attack the
knight yeah go for it
so now he attacks your Bishop but but
look you're your Bishop is defended by
the knight so you don't really have to
react to that so hard okay so but he
takes and takes and now you play d4
opening it up so now he he decides to
play the move d5 which really didn't
correspond to your last move so you
could have ideas like ninety five to
attack the Queen or you know some stuff
but but however you play you take his
pawn he takes back you take his pawn but
now when you do that
see there's one player attacking your
night for real here
the night right but through an x-ray
this Bishop is attacking the night so
and this guy is the one that's shielding
the x-ray right it's like the block you
can wear like so I can't see see through
you
so when you take that now when he takes
you away if he would take you like that
and then he would get this nasty fork on
you with the two rooks okay so you got
to watch out for that so a simple way to
do is just take the knight here and then
that would limit the complications and
also as we know from the previous
lectures when somebody takes something
of yours
they might really really want to be on
that square anyway why does that night
really want to be on that square what
besides is night what else is he
attacking when he takes that pawn yes a
jail what what else can that Knight
capture besides this white knight his
queen he wishes he could take to clean
but what else what's the closest thing
to this Knight here the bishop right
when the night goes over over up takes
the bishop so always keep that in mind
just because when they take something
they might have other other ulterior
motives to be on that square that that's
a really complicated thing to know
sometimes so okay so that was even
better so it sorry and also it's much
better to win a piece outright than to
win the exchange like Knight takes pawn
takes Bishop takes right so always I
always keep that in mind too
all right so Knight takes up for a free
piece and so attacks the free piece so
now what move could black make in this
position that would totally
devastate white here does anybody see a
shack I see two checks so so night h nh3
looks really good and and you don't even
want to ever get your night out of here
you just want them resting there because
like obviously right if if king goes
here or there right the night you can
put the night the night isn't a pin and
we can attack the pin piece if he goes
to f1 then we take and we're threatening
checkmate
i mean it's just it's just great so so
don't be afraid to check he was afraid
he was gonna get his night trap down
there but whatever all right or even in
this position even Bishop g4 you know
now we have two players on this on
Knight is really really good but check
is just great
alright you say retreats the e6 and not
impressed so he protects the pawn but by
protecting the pawn what was that pawn
doing on b2 that obviously is no longer
doing on b4 yeah protecting the night so
so you never want to voluntarily remove
the defenders of your pieces and you see
now the bishop
really likes to be on that square -
because he's attacking both of your
Brooks so you make a counter attack I
like it attacks the night so he just
like he could just move his Queen to
safety and he still have the the fort
going but he's like I just I just eat up
it ate it all up
alright so b5 and so now f3 Queen and
Bishop are in a battery coming down
attacking f3 so he protects it but he
stays in the pin
alright so rook attacks the Queen clean
up h6 so so so right so in this position
right black ones to attack f3 alright so
he prepares at h6 Knight g5 does he have
a much faster move here besides h6 95 to
attack f3 where could that night go
right now that would attack the pawn d4
excellent and it attacks the Queen in
the process that would have been major
instead he's like he plays too slow
the rings away said that is because he
didn't want this this king to be able to
fly to h3 but whatever
rook III and now black has a great
tactic here he should just take the pawn
right cuz however he takes it
rook there we can just I don't want to
mess this up I got a calculate this we
could uh yeah yeah just work d2 now
right it's got it's got to be Rick d2
right now come down here rook g2 so
obviously has to take it right because
he doesn't wanna lose his Queen and then
Queen check well it goes there oh yeah
checkmate we don't even want to dump her
okay yeah all right great
alright so instead he plays plays H 5 H
4 and he goes back to e6 King gets up
have five rook up attacks and when he
takes unfortunately all of his plans
come to glory but what should he play
for real when f5 is played here you got
a big chance to come back in this game
Dillon
at work take c60 he voluntarily removed
the defender of his night
so that's unfortunately yeah and when he
takes obviously he gets fort and the
game doesn't last very much longer
he Queen takes pawn obviously the best
but but James sees a like a main six or
seven here and checked and it really
doesn't mess it up too bad
can anybody see the checkmate here and
it's double checkmate if you can believe
it yeah I would allow the King to go to
g1 workout for one double checkmate
who's really checkmating the King in
this position nobody knows the bishop
alright he knows Craig knows it's the
bishop alright so he gets the he gets
the win alright so so that's that's a
game and but but you know Diller he
didn't give up in the game and he had a
chance to maybe make a little bit of
noise if you would have taken the night
so in this game he also doesn't give up
here he just keeps going and maybe
something good will happen Dylan has
white against Ben shortcut rated 1100
even though
Dylan's rated 685 but well yeah he's bad
intimidated he's gonna play and see what
happens so once again Dylan has the
white pieces and he starts out for a
Benjamin plays a c5 Bishop c4 knight c6
b3 this is kind of dangerous so so in
this position I mean this should be like
an automatic move for you right here you
played b3 the reason why you play b3
right is the fianchetto your bishop
right so do it alright excellent so you
did it good good good
Knight f6 Knight f3 Bishop g7 all right
he got castle again castled quick that's
good
you got castled Knight c3 and then yeah
unfortunately unfortunately you got to
be wary of these tactics so Knight c3
there's a big we did a big piece on that
and that Eric tank chinko lecture yeah
there's a lot of tactics that can happen
on here so you got to be really careful
that's why it's much better as white is
to get your Bishop Bishop out here and
your Queen and Bishop and a battery and
trying to come down and get them so
instead of trying to challenge along the
Finca shuttle so so once again he's got
one he's got one two players on this
night and you only have one defender
even two defenders okay so so it's very
common for hey I'm going to attack you
know I'm mad I just got taken it so I'm
gonna attack you but once again you
voluntarily remove the defender of the
piece so Knight takes and he knows very
smart like he wants to save this
dark-squared bishop because it's gonna
hold everything together
so that was smart of Benjamin all right
so he moves the rook 86-83
all right and now oh man your bishop is
trapped here so but you get a pawn for
it alright and you look at this position
he's playing somebody like almost double
his rating he's down a couple pieces but
have no fear right we're gonna do this
we're gonna do it some way or the other
we're gonna do it we're gonna do it
alright alright so Benjamin pins the
night now in this position I would go
ahead well actually I will go ahead and
play Knight to d4 huh alright same thing
well Knight to d4 might be a little more
accurate because you're
attacking the Queen right oh yeah and
Wow so awesome
well maybe not awesome all right so
Queen efore all right so wait so he
can't resist he's just gonna take
anyone's stay in this position you
probably want to take with the night
check and then the [ __ ] day and then
you have the two bishops and you'll be
doing good but he can't resist because
he wants to get this last check in and
now he's putting up peace all right so
he's attacking the pawn so maybe we'll
just play f3 or work to e1 here so he's
got a tactic with Knight takes b3
possibly but that might fall bad to rook
to e3 so let's see what Benjamin ended
up doing all right so he tries it but
that might be really risky cuz of rook
to e3 here okay so rookie 3 he got a
little too greedy
so rook attacks the rook so just take
with check take and now we got a bishop
back we got a fish up all right the
comeback it's on all right Knight up so
so black has one two three four five six
seven and you got one two three four
five and down a knight
so it's gonna be tough but making some
more of a comeback here b5 so we just
attack the a pawn right or the b-pawn if
my honest lady in this position if so
why it's objective should be to try to
eliminate these Queen side pawns even if
it takes his King side pawns and then
try to get an endgame just like on one
half of the board because if if somehow
black could have a passed pawn over here
this one rook is going to do a horrible
job at stopping them so rook up so c4
excellent alright so Brooke takes
all right so so it's offering a rook
trade sure you take it absolutely not
right you don't want to trade your last
hope of winning or drawing the game a
lot of people will do well you know if
we trade the rooks the game's gonna get
a lot over a lot sooner right because
I'm in blacks is gonna win the a pond
with this night and right raced on the a
point so a lot of people think like that
unfortunately like oh if we trade the
rooks the game's gonna get over in five
minutes instead of uh you know ten or
fifteen but you have no chance to win so
so yeah attack the a pond excellent but
then he attacks yours so hopefully you
play uh with the c3 in this position
good got to protect that a pawn if you
lose the a pond and you might as well
just traded the rooks cuz you're gonna
that'd be good okay so it takes that
pawn but that's okay we stole still got
this a pawn here so he attacks the rook
he sees it attacks the rook he sees it
again so now we attack the a pond he
moves the a pawn we attack the a pawn he
should play okay okay well this is good
too so we got to get this heap on then
we got to get something for it check
block it attacks the pinned piece so so
what everybody's probably in this
position
there's no way black can get back row
checkmated right because you can always
flee there so so we could just go on
autopilot we don't have to worry about
getting back row checkmated right i
always have to worry about getting back
row checkmated if your kings on the back
row guess what you can get back row
checkmated right doesn't matter how many
people are out
all right so Knight up King up pawn up
hang up oh you know what the best move
in this position is
gödel f6 well you never play off six f5
alright okay okay the computers like top
like ups like just play up five all
right Ben you want it you want that you
want that pawn don't you you want all
your stuff I want all your stuff instead
he attacks it again because he wants to
take it with checkmate huh threaten his
own checkmate
it's like the end of Star Wars
everybody's so close to crushing each
other and until it gets that first
triumph good prevails good job okay if
you think that was a great comeback
alright you ain't seen nothing yet
alright so so Jaden is the hero even
though he's probably mathematically
eliminated from winning the game but but
don't worry he'll find a way he's
playing Michael Pugachev ok and this is
the last round of the tournament
ok and so if you guys are playing in
tournaments
so Michael Poggi if this was his very
first tournament he just came off of a
glorious win at the kids beginner
tournament to win a USDF membership to
be eligible to play and so he was 3 you
know he was doing great and he wanted to
play a journey you know
the top seed in the last round it said
adjourn get to play uh this other kid
that was three you know Blake so so when
Michael pugachov sat down to play this
game he was all like complaining about
the pairings why didn't I am i pair like
this why am i pair like that so he
wasn't really concentrating on on the
game as you'll see it really doesn't
affect them at the beginning but uh but
you know no pairings are the pans right
so just just just play your game to the
best of your ability and then hopefully
you know maybe the tiebreaker would have
worked out in his favor anyway and what
a war in the first place if he would've
won but we'll see so so here's pukka
Jeff he's playing with the white pieces
and yeah if you would win this game he
would get a rating of 1525 so d4c 5
alright so so
if I played this move a lot obviously
James from my student and he needs to
take right away because because this is
no good if they play d5 and then you'll
just have no space and and you're doing
very poor so Knight up d6 Bishop to b5
pins the night
so check hopefully he's hoping that he
wins the bishop here right but what does
white have to play here so he can he can
get his uh yeah Knight to c3 excellent
see see what he did there he blocked the
check and protected the piece excellent
so now he gets out of the pin
so Bishop takes Bishop takes Bishop d2
so you should always be looking at
what's in the same lines right it's not
that difficult
so you just played Bishop the d2 you
know to do a discovered attack here okay
so get out of the line and now you're
stopping the King from castling so Queen
e2 so check you know in this position I
I would just take with the King connect
the rooks cuz you're essentially in an
endgame right now even though you don't
even know it
but yeah the Queen's are off the board
you've got no risk of checkmate and the
heck with the two bishops I'm gonna
destroy your your pawn structure okay
but he doesn't now his whole idea right
now is a wall he wants to get castle
Jaden does so Knight f6 Castle g6 I mean
they're in an endgame in the endgame you
want your King in the center right put
but he just can't wait to get castled
here so be three so we know how
dangerous that could be the bishop on
the same a diagonal so not recommended
here rook e8 you probably want to work
on c8 the half-open files sent a 8 does
not them so pawn takes pawn takes Knight
attacks the bishop Knight attacks the
bishop so so do we want to let this
happen Knight takes bishop the pawn
takes the answer is no we want to
protect the bishop with c8 so if he
takes we don't have to have such a bad
bad pawn structure isolate upon double
isolated pawns so obviously it takes
with the rook Knight attacks the pawn so
we could just attack it right and you
have to go back all right so he plays
rook to d6 what's better than rook the
d6 how about this rook that's not doing
anything on 8 to get on there okay just
these little moves add up so II for
threatening of course II five the pawn
fork in this position you know he could
still play rook the DA cuz if he plays
d5 now we just take the bishop all right
but all right so he gets scared and he
plays e5 leaving a nice nice hole on d5
for white here obviously you don't want
to jump into it right now
but you want to prepare it so he should
play if I was playing white every pipe
play a bishop here attacks the pawn and
gets all these rooks like going
challenge the power all right Burke
everyone protects the pawn now he
doubles the rooks
rookie to b5 f3 Knight up a 4 so now you
tax the night but the knight can jump
into the hole now so that didn't really
work out too well for him
so now Knight attacks the night and it
gets taken not good Jaden so so Jane
thought he had some pressure but he
really didn't in reality so rook back f5
trying to remove the defender so I know
what I played in this position when I
would play rook to d3
I probably would have played uh maybe
just king well King to f1 but oh well
alright so look the d3 and now check
King up some pawn takes pawn takes
Bishop d4 it doubles the rooks so it so
now this check could become a big deal
so he gets out of the check King up
protects so now he's just like let's
trade let's trade everything here so
he's got to trade at least one rook so
he does does so now now the questions on
Jane he's got six pawns his opponent has
seven does he want to do it he says I'm
going for it alright so now so now his
opponent has a passed pawn here
but the only thing he has going for him
is a 3/3 pawn to to majority okay so he
better figure something out with this
quick or else this past ponds gonna be
the difference so he attacks the night
and look this night is a monster right
there's no possible way you know this
night can ever be thrown out of f5 here
even if King up six you can't take it so
but he moves it anyway you're going for
the fork Jack doesn't do anything
alright alright so now Jane has a chance
here
what well yeah he does have a chance
here because if he plays the move
check the King can't take the pawn
obviously because the knight will get
taken so so Jane really missed his
opportunity to give a nice check to the
King instead he plays a miserable move
Bishop takes f2 and now he is he's gone
into a losing King and pawn endgame
so now he creates his own passed pawn
right so he thinks he's doing well but
as we'll see if this King ever takes
this pawn right this pawn is home free
so so in a king upon endgame the king
can never take the protector of a passed
pawn everybody understand that you can
win and lose a lot of end games with
that tactic okay like for instance well
you get the drift all right so he's just
gonna race his is passed pawn due to
death and now he's like well forget it
now I got to do something or else he
can't just sit around and do nothing or
else this King could come over and just
just escort that pawn straight down to
EA so you know he might as well try
something right so yes in this in this
instance here after takes right he needs
to play the move
c5 cuz if pawn takes now he's got his
own passer thank you all right but
instead he's like I'm just going to
gobble up all your pawns
so check so so this is a thing it's
classic games you can never be too can
never give up because you know if you
have anything going for you you got to
play so another check and that that's a
really really bad check here cuz
obviously what would black do to get out
of this check see - yeah just push the
pawn you're one step closer to to
getting your queen so now white probably
there's only hope here is to get a
perpetual check going and instead
he's like okay this pawns in a pen I can
just move my king out not the way to do
it so now Jade probably just pushes his
king up excellent and he's got no checks
so the only thing he could possibly do
in this position is maybe trying to pin
pin the dude but I think it's too late
anyway so now he's like well if you take
me if you get your Queen I'm gonna take
you with check and then I'm gonna have a
lot of nice checks okay so what do we do
here
probably just push the pawn huh
plays the move a5 tricky tricky let's
see what the computer lets default of
the computer here for a minute I guess
so they're saying it's just a dead draw
but after a five if he takes a five here
then he would push b3 and things will be
going okay for him for white actually
wait wait which which piece or do I have
to press here all right
so Jane does the tricky a five and
Pugachev does not take the a pawn so he
just gets a queen and now he's got more
pawns and a queen and he'll be doing
well Queen takes pawn here check King up
b3 discovered attack on the Queen's
check he takes and obviously he's a lot
he's gonna win this race all right so
what room do you think Jaden plays just
to win the game here mm-hmm
Queen to b7 okay this this this should
be just as easy though for you yeah
that's exactly what happens so he plays
Queen - b7 check and you know wins the
game but what if white would try King to
c6 here what is the easiest way to win
this game because wouldn't everybody
agree you would hate to see a position
like like if the king was like down here
and everything so what is a really easy
move for black to play in this position
is just the end all hope for white ever
getting a queen - a 8 Queen to be a
excellent you agree with that and then
an a it's got nothing
in game over right it's a very easy way
to go there and so so those that was the
that was the SummerSlam bash here's a
here's some of the photos of the winter
so you can put some some names to the
the faces here so we got a Gaussian to
one fifth place alright he's already
doubled in strength since uh since I
take over teaching them we got
Pugachev there's Prue good show
he finished fourth place so now we got
we got the big winners here in second
place Jaden
all right there's the the guy from
Florida all right the gentleman from
Florida he got the top under 800 here
Dylan all right
and he actually got a bigger trophy than
the fifth place finisher good job good
job and then of course everybody knows
who won the event
good old ya adjourn is out just seven
seven years old here the the Grand
Champion on the SummerSlam bash so that
was the bash for ya